[Music]
hello hello hello what's up everybody
I'm sorry we are 2 minutes late but it's
alright there you go awesome I can hear
myself now thank you
but Persia what are we what are we up to
today right now we are gonna play some
call of duty black ops 4 because we just
had a huge update a huge patch 3 yep so
boom boom
yeah spectres a thing yeah he has a new
specialist so he's like the assassin
he's like gonna run up on you you got a
smoke grenade all that good stuff so got
a sword pretty fun sword and I think
there's like also a mode where like you
have to become the spectre and then
assassin e-everyone and then it kind of
like passes off power if you kill the
spectre and so on so forth so we try to
try that out alright and yeah there's a
bunch of modes we're gonna try to get
through as much of it as possible it's a
pretty big update you have a list I'll
let you you're prepared I'm not we have
the addition of prop hunt actually one
of my like personal favorite game types
it's one of those game types really you
don't really want to go try hard and you
just want to like play and it's
hilarious because alright the props are
pretty hilarious so I want to try to
play one of those capture the flag
pretty cool yes ETF that's like standard
FPS game type and now it is back so
that's cool also some new maps artifact
wmd masquerade and then a new alternate
map of haciendas so awesome I can only
assume that's like a nighttime version
yeah so regular huskiness cool I'm down
for that and then blackout you said
you've played more of the blackout modes
so you might be able to feel the impact
of these updates a little bit more so
let's see new map updates till Wetworks
and Alcatraz new game modes bounty
hunter that's the one with the spectre
mooninites
bounty hunter ground war so we call all
the homies everyone complains like the
big battle massive scale team versus
team combats and then new playable
characters Uncle Frank misty sergej
Sergei they're going there we go Sara
hall blackjack David Mason and the new
equipment and weapons
so date plus war under such promises so
what do you want to do first I mean
let's just at least kick it off with
some prop hunt okay
because Brocklin is probably gonna be
the more fun version before we can get
to this the insane stuff I would have
thought of you here yeah real tough oh
wait no that's our course featured is
this one of those times where like it's
part of like another thing and you just
have to like no no sometimes like they
have that weird thing where you have to
play a certain thing and then like it's
part of like a playlist but I'm like
check me out help chat hell I need help
I want you is there anything else
yeah play some domination we'll try out
spec yeah if we can get him because
sometimes you can only other one who
clasper I think if you play TDM you can
have multiple spectres all right let's
try that I think hopefully I'm not wrong
I'm pretty sure though if you play TDM
you can you can have multiple spectators
I think this is still on my my controls
my controllers a little bit are you uh
inverted I am NOT okay I am tactical
it's only one only only Erin's inverted
in this office it's like Playstation or
Xbox and you're like oh we got trouble
alright cool got a game a level 300 no
problem
good thing you level with my character
some I try to you know get some better
gun what's your favorite so far my
favorite gun so far ah probably the
Spitfire but you know it's pretty close
range so I've been using the rampart for
like those range maps okay um but you
know there's still better weapons
they're just on the horizon we're only
like level 20 or something yeah 3232
can we play the new Matt Oh pop pop punk
comes out Friday I guess there you go
they're kind of like trickling agreeing
trickling the the content I guess I
expect great things so so the
interesting thing is I went back and
looked at Spector when he was in black
ops 3 I believe is 3 and his like melee
was different he almost had like it was
like his alt and he it was like predator
where was like came out of his like
wrist
whereas this in black ops wore its
shared up sword
so we'll see are you guys gonna do
portal hints 3 after this no but come
back tomorrow box man will be checking
out the borderlands 3 presentation and
then some of our folks will get hands-on
to this is an old map if anyone didn't
know but are you guys related no I mean
we're all part of the games that's true
that is all right big damage big damage
now you're good alright that was
challenging too hard yeah it's like the
head camp spot I guess it's like a snow
version I don't recall like yeah you all
you saw show that guy like multiple
times now ok first game of the day yeah
woman oh I didn't give you any time to
warm up because
they know the spots I know I'm like I
want to stay on the outskirts cluster
okay I'm how unlock to me
smoke grenade right is that what his
tactical is yeah that's what you get for
reloading yeah here we go oh you almost
hit the dolphin I like it good the insta
prone that's just like old school Co D
tactics that'll never leave my soul I
think you know that the stream was set
up an hour early today no I didn't know
that crime I know I just haven't
unlocked rapid fire for this yeah enemy
strike team deploy that call hostile
hailstorm inbound
oh we got barricade to barbecue yeah she
was using impart now she's using the
Spitfire I'm indoors okay because like
in cod all SMGs are good even more way
is just what it did that's just what it
is good we are cxd in your AO even in
Apex the r99
good from four hey why is he not
shooting me because it's one of those
guys is a fake no he's real he's really
like a killstreak almost can I make this
jump almost watch out for the barbed
wire yeah it takes a lot of damage or it
used to I think it's not as bad now but
it's still pretty pretty tough to get
rid of probably you crying I know I know
as you thank you for figuring it out
that's my bad I hope I don't get that
one map that's all like sands for me
hoping we get one of the new ones rate
WMV that's one of the old but new ones
sure if they're like staggered to
where's my boy in the chat that helped
us one time does your buddy I think that
died horrible death this is the hot spot
I guess I guess so go around it's
usually my plan of action if I see where
there's to me of my own teammates in one
spot
over here okay sighs all right we're
gonna do all right all right at least we
know you're going to get your altough
later the supreme otaku yeah yeah so
hopefully we get some of the new masters
as you mentioned earlier maskers
artifact WMD and a new alternative map
oh yeah how you gonna use this yeah I
should have saved my smoke you play
overwatch I do
Oh so maybe this is like a yeah I know
right like that alt logo looks like
I just realized yeah I'll move the
picture-in-picture later guys
I realize that we're blocking the
Spitfire not that that really matters in
hindsight I don't think it matters what
gun I'd be using wait man I'm gonna get
close enough to activate circling
you gotta hope that like one of your
pops like you a beautiful Oh get that
guy too
oh you can roll so lt's aim and our
threes roll so you can do a roll if you
have to oh dude it lasts so long
oh well barrel roll there alright fine a
little do bleh kill oh yeah yeah you
still have like half half of the supers
are ultimate whatever you want to call
it alright alright yeah they'll never
know oh it's okay it was too good it was
too good it was too good you got like
six kills off okay use the oh you had
the he had that geraldo I was like the
sword the sword worked great the sword
is fantastic I wish I could have that
jenji I guess that's what the Spitfire
was good for their clothes the people
yeah the people like in quickscope I'm
always like yeah he does it oh that's
the same guy almost very close
I miss the box I saw - yeah yeah cards a
lot about that about like positioning
Wow oh they're coming in ah oh you can
take that scary fake dots on yeah
[Music]
they're everywhere
according to the map this is what my
mind looks like we're normal and Hopi
Johnson thinks they ruin us out there
and that's a black ops II version is
better it's kind of the same to be
honest this one's probably more friendly
because the other one like I said it was
more like a predator claw thing where
you had to get like I mean you still
have to get the free place on this one
but hey you that alt was sick yeah got
like six kills that was definitely worth
it yeah I actually should have been add
that on and recording it but you know
we'll get another one will totally get
another one how do you want to move it
so here I'm gonna want you to go full
game yeah and then yeah I will help out
okay oh good so clearly that all is
amazing I can definitely see that mixed
with the smoke grenade being pretty
pretty fun imagine that on Nuketown
ah let's see
I'm so sad we can't play proppant until
Friday this prop plant in the modern
warfare remastered version right now and
it is so fun it's actually hilarious
though because some of the props you
would never expect like an actual tree
like a whole tree okay so our three is
roll that was fun and then I can
actually aim the sword I was just
swinging it and it was working out so
that's fine too you
it shouldn't have actually pushed that
live I spy oh no oh we don't have what
how why not in anagen what is okay that
kicked because we didn't have the map oh
I have everything I bought everything
this morning just got we have to
download it from the Blackman I don't
know I don't think so I don't why would
a map there's no way a map could be Wow
bother maybe the trailer hi why these
skins it's so epic
you want that that's how cool actually
that I don't care for
I'm pretty sure it's all installed but I
mean cuz from what I know so I don't
think so like it shouldn't be part of
the emote wheel because I mean when I
checked the because I thought we didn't
have Spectre for a second and then I was
like oh I got to get him from the and
the battle pass which I did and then I
bought that thing the 30 I think is
$39.99 or is it a multiplayer pax no
those are all free see so okay so it
says you get the maps let's find out
cosmetic trailer incoming yeah pretty
much yeah have instant access to three
multiples we just have to download it
I'm gonna see myself out now it actually
done though I will find out possibly all
right so I can only assume that's gonna
download while we play you think so I
mean the only way to tell later is like
oh no it's locked
is it because it's probably downloading
right fun times we clearly know we're
doing okay well you can hit uh here I'll
go hopefully this works
you can go hit the PlayStation one and
then we'll find out for sure go up
ya know downloading that bigger bus and
we're back
alright let me try I know you got it
like five six kills off the thing II
actually don't like oh is this something
you have to unlock waiter that gun
shoots okay let's go back to the did I
did we download the other one to find
out
so I multiplayer hacks try
checking both of those yeah let's let's
just let's get them all let's just get
all free yeah apparently I definitely
played this one though but who knows
maybe they added more later
all right download that one too it's
alright
get out of there go to yeah let's do
grand heist - I definitely didn't play
this one I'll be honest
thanks for tuning in you guys thanks for
the tips Pro tips PlayStation download
times are atrocious no actually I don't
know I didn't mean you were good it's
not locked
yeah see how it was locked earlier I
feel good about it this time watch it's
not gonna work again
hello Satoshi
welcome back crime and everybody else
box night what's up
alright alright alright we're gonna
expect there again nurse she's an
inspector again hopefully destroy like
you just did again might need another
controller for some zombies though oh
that I did not bring in it's also uh if
I recall correctly I tried split screen
with Rob one time and it was not a good
but it was like it got kind of chunky
like it was like downgrading like the
resolution and stuff like that to kind
of compensate oh we got a new map WMD
good thing we downloaded those Maps
and you think we were prepared I was
it's my fault I gotta make it so that
either I'm not on these Tuesday ones or
that I move one of my tables if I have
back-to-back meetings before this which
is not ideal
you got him
I will not be able to deal with it
oh this man it's been so long yeah oh
they got a squad ready
oh good you filled the strike team guys
cool yeah they're dominating you guys I
guess if that guy has a strike team the
strike team needs to be super Opie
though yep
ring around the Rosie we'll get played
yeah I like you you got played he
thought you went up top you actually ran
in a circle I'm like no she's it she's
in the zone
she's in the zone yeah once it hey
that's fair Oh your legs there he did a
roll into the old the thing is nice body
at the end oh yeah you got him
oh no that's us oh no he killed us
already okay who does he get who does he
get oh hi it was kind of Opie it is like
realtalk
oh hi you place them in the back and is
like a mom
yeah no spoilers for vendors in here are
you you will be okay I will get you gone
yeah yeah give people time it's still
fresh
yeah it's still only been a couple days
you know I I I feel bad for the folks
that you know like if they had a busy
weekend or if they're out of town or
something they couldn't watch it they're
like trying to stay off social media no
these three you're like I mean I didn't
see it until Sunday night and I had to
stay off of social on yeah like you just
can't because you don't know like I
think most people are pretty good about
it but yeah even an NFL football player
he tweeted spoilers and everyone was
hating on him for it
LeSean McCoy for anyone that was curious
yeah it was on ESPN itself but yeah but
then I thought about it an Espeon zone
by Disney so I'm like everything's like
everything like they have a monopoly
people just don't understand I think and
then each like stone is like a property
or something that I think could be a guy
Fox know like all right so let's plan
our course of action yeah for what else
we're gonna try out played some blackout
we can try it's been a minute but we can
try and I can we can see what's up
there's like the flag out you can look
at the modes and see what what we got
everything looks the game all the core
stuffs this looks the same because I
didn't see capture the flag I don't see
prop on they said additional barebone
modes but I don't know which ones those
are we didn't see ground war either
right so Oh
WMD again okay this time at least you
get to start yeah
give me that mouse see this is also why
I didn't go on social and be like I
don't wanna get well because I knew
someone would do it on purpose but hit
[Music]
one of those things where like I just
got rid of the wrong person
oh no it's super sorry to social fix it
actually I can't bring them back it's
okay they're just in I just put that
person in timeout no okay Frank lists I
wish it was more like twitch where you
can just click the name there now I have
I'm sorry toast I hope you come back
it's I will apologize once you get back
to yeah no no any spoilers even if
they're troll spoilers I don't want to
see him anyways back to some spectral
vector action trying to get my old says
fast as possible classic tale yeah you
know another old map why can they mean
new maps because sometimes that's the
good stuff
I like this map when I from back in the
day it's actually kind of cool seeing
them again ooh I like it the Crouch tech
okay yeah oh very good very good
oh why am I not recording any of this
good but sometimes that's the beauty of
it though like you just actually like
even for myself like that's that's how I
works right you like chill in a room you
kill multiple people and they're like so
salty even myself they want the run back
they want the run back so they come back
for you and then you film again immortal
the old cybus the bait-and-switch
all right crime I got it I gotta get you
access I'm pretty sure it's like a Drake
icon that's pretty cool actually
he's like a winky face Drake I see
you're you're very well trained to not
be like yeah you know all day yesterday
I had to entrain that because I was
getting a little it's actually like a
halo habit yeah I noticed it's the right
thing to do like you wanna like you
still have bullets in your mag
this is a healing I yeah that's that's
the one thing I have to remember to
forget a lot to coming back yeah purges
playing not me I would not be able to
kill too many people as she did just now
but I guess I'm supposed to try up in
black it's gonna go well guys smoke
assist yeah Oh your whole teammate died
to the right jenji time okay okay there
you go
oh you got like our only skin - that's
it
I was satisfied still funny yeah you did
that sweet roll
sweet roll and then his buddy came up
right behind him died in the same
terrible way he's camping
oh he's built a little fort I didn't
even notice the fire are you available
oh he is he built himself a little boy
oh just watch out for the barb yeah I
like it though I like that you don't
want him to live in his house ain't
nobody ain't nobody come yeah he was
close I know I know I know I'm with you
on that it's just it's hard to do the
180s yeah there's no 360 noscope I don't
know man he's got a kill streak he's not
good looks like the Rolling Thunder one
that keeps coming oh hey to run past
there hey she didn't want the advantage
she'll get it next time
the funny thing is a dirt one night when
I use crash I do that I do that assault
pack for myself but there are certain
game types where the salt pack gives you
so much to your kill streak score thing
that it's actually okay
okay you got the crash or you had the
crash buff yes yeah like it gives you
more health I like the pre-fire get free
fire they're like you're gonna come out
on this side I know you are wait chop
your hand off third person mode is
pretty yeah okay here we go
here we go they'll never know all right
I feel like this is a decent map for it
too
okay oh I was trying to make some some
god plays I like it +25 oh that scared
me that button looked like a mesh mine
but it won an oblate dude the blade is
pretty sick gotta play me some Specter
hey your first first on the team try to
put them on your put them on the back oh
I feel like you get chopped in this and
he's got the mask on like I feel the
full
look at the blood splatter - it stays oh
he follow people thank you oh right now
still got a triple sort of I would have
been so sad toast on fire I'm so sorry
welcome back you're free I I did it I
had to get rid of somebody and I because
of how like the YouTube chat is I have
to like it's these little three lines
here and I have to kind of eyeball guess
who it is so apologies hopefully you get
another master look at that we have
we're leveling up our battle past 1.6
that's really good I if I get over 1
Katie I'm like did did didn't didn't
hurt my team didn't totally help my team
but I was like you know you're you're
living the average right but you're
you're you're doing the best on your
team doing all you could with a new
character you know you specialist yeah
that was not new unfortunately I want to
see masquerade maybe I should back out
until we get a new one you do what your
heart tells you do you see I'm gonna use
the power of the Internet to
double-check when all this stuff comes
out cuz that would be good to know all
right so we got it on camera and that I
went positive one game I guess you're
positive yo games too though like I feel
like oh really okay III don't remember
the ones I go less than one Katie I only
remember the ones that are good you know
but yes Specter is pretty cool
I think it's kind of good that they made
him different than before but kind of
still gave that same vibe mm-hmm I like
that smoke grenade - it's pretty cool
that it kind of gives off feels like a
scouting tool - you got that before they
get you
sure thing boss gotta learn the map
right like the Call of Duty classic you
run around the whole math and then don't
find anything yeah and they're on the
other side then you get that bad respawn
someone bad response oh wait I think I
remember this map it just looks a little
bit more green than it used to have
dates it has a way in the church so
launch week for this wait what
all right I need another confirm or deny
that problem isn't so it is yeah is is
later this week that's the second person
toast on fire who I again sorry
toast tell me what else is like
staggered other than prop one like cuz
clear clearly capture the flags not in
either right now oh that theirs are
yours well might be ours
I just I was scared it's better to be
somebody for sure oh that guy's Bosch
nice oh how did you not get a smoke we
sort fished it
yes mocha cyst what that noise is just
so nerve-racking
Tony G if you want to play Spector I
would say play a TDM because it doesn't
matter how many inspectors there are on
a team
this is the hot spot we have found it
this little area it's only hot when I'm
not around
he's so emo - he's like my Reaper you'd
be surprised how quick for ignite tedium
you can only run - well we haven't had a
problem getting Spectre well also maybe
not everyone owns it either
all right
your sword sword just going for a stroll
oh they see me that's not my smoke I was
like ooh smoke safe it's safe right all
right the new weapons are tiger shark
LMG and the new Evo ot melee weapons
who's everyone enemy UAV above found oh
my god useless game they lose in the
fight
everyone own is it it's free yeah well
we still had to download it I still had
to unlock him in the in the tear pass or
the battle pathway or whatever didn't
even want to kill you though or took a
different route oh they're coming back
up okay
doesn't say they're bad you can you can
fix it because it's like 2/3 of their
clip I got a shank waitin yeah they have
counter UAV just me no okay I don't
think that counts against your old
you're in the animation fortunately for
you
[Music]
okay oh my gosh no one was there okay
okay
still good Oh does he know he doesn't
think he I don't think he so it turns
red yeah it did that kind of black ops 3
- it would kind of highlight one you
could just like I think I should yeah
you didn't have to right yeah somebody
did bodies
do I dare
nice the alt lasts a long time yeah so
long okay
don't let it put you on till now I know
that feeling
it's how I feel sometimes when I'm
shooting a wingman and then you start
missing just like I can't hit anything
and then you spray and pray okay okay he
uses all to kill that's pretty smile is
like can't see yeah yeah but you only
had six health so you're probably dead
anyway
all right clean it up yup here we go
coming back sometimes you just gotta get
those momentum swings no he's fine he's
like et me like oh that guy is dead just
waiting in the church he's protecting
the church how are you oh yeah yeah oh
it's great it's best please yeah
Kellan
okay she's gotta get a third right well
stab you stab say things he lives
through this yeah huh hey I felt like it
would've been the perfect amount for a
goalie killed one phrase that's all
right you set high expectations you know
you went from getting six like right off
the bat like oh oh this is just swing
the sword easy no I don't buy that
[Music]
okay okay let's do classified in hopes
that we know but at least it's nighttime
firing but I think that's that's not
gonna be a good one yeah Friday though
you guys play some prop hunt it sounds
like it's not that fun but trust me it
is sometimes you'll be like an orange or
sometimes you'll be a tree or sometimes
you'll be a hole garbage dumpsters sweet
garbage dumpster and you'd be surprised
how easy it would be to just like hide
in plain sight and people will walk by
you and not not recognize it eventually
though after a few rounds you'll just
start shooting everything just to be
sure and then they get you that way
right yes but being a prop is super
cheap because you get like a flashbang
and then you can change into a different
robbed like once or twice depending on
all right you guys Specter that's good
yes
how'd you like em Caleb and crime
m'kay lemons pretty good fun now that
I've been playing how do you plated MK
before no there's actually my first time
like actually picking it up Oh like I'm
like button match like happen but like
actually hitting the lab and learning
some combos it was pretty cool
that's cool with your lunch I've been
using scarlet oh okay bugs a big lobby
taking the lead
Thank You Bernardo yeah this starts
morning I think yeah we switched that's
still the one thing I mean like if you
get really good you start to read read
the and know the Swans but like
sometimes I'm like oh my gosh
yeah you're not ready for that crouch
tech no you're not double kill smoke
tube they're gonna come back for the run
back you know yeah
oh they're back or they were they were
an hour you go views gun oh yeah you
ruined your kill streak he actually
psych me I thought it was very good
getting that extra 25 oh that guy's
gonna kill him right yeah he sliced them
you chopped him oh wow that guy got
sword ready that's fast
juice me okay hot spot hot spot okay
good night then we're ready for the roll
the Jeep Jeep is a good spot it is
advised
that's a lie we do not now we all
there's a lot it's hot
yes I know I was like it's about the
right now yeah you're getting pinched
anyway unfortunate uses his tactical and
his loser skill shots I give credit
[Music]
yeah if you guys want borderlines three
stuff the gameplay reveal presentation
it's tomorrow morning and then we have
some hands-on gameplay after that come
back Thursday I can say right it's out
that update is join Persia and a special
guest okay I'm just gonna be cuz you're
gonna be playing Power Rangers now for
the grid because there is a new update
right and you're gonna get clockwork in
guys no clockwork okay and he's gonna
you guys know sway a bit talk about the
update and it's a massive update like
it's totally different
we added some new characters I made a
bunch of updates
sorry to cut you off there it was like I
just remember it it only man remember
that one time me and been played and we
liked that story what do you watch out
now yeah oh do you want to take a stab
at some black Oh we'll try no promises I
think one of the new maps was on that
really here let me see if we'll find a
real quick maybe we'll go back into the
same lobby
yeah here I'll play with your loadout
this is will be my warmup tactical so
your Crouch is gonna be your R 3 and
your beatdown is your B button oh you
have different buttons yeah
say that again so to crouch is R 3 and
to be down circle
oh so you swap those two can I swap them
back yeah ok let's connect to a regular
loadout
yeah let me default it it's like oh it's
like that's some ice it's got some like
volcano a venti areas there was a crash
of some sort
all the way down to button layout go to
the left oh so there is one that like
you like ready that's like a preset
rather ok but yeah crime says beat the
developer in his own game oh that's
probably not gonna happen if everybody
knows who clockwork is he is legendary
fighting game player and I kind of think
it's really dope that a fighting game
player like going on to design you know
a fighting game
you know you're gonna get some some nice
quality look at just a little bit you
say rampart we're not yeah holding me
down for a few games but yes new map
let's go
it's true it's nice and icy it has all
the elements thank you for saving me
yeah that sounds about right
a lot of little caves this is a great
start
why do you know what it is - it's like I
the only real FPS game I've been playing
is like legends and I thought you said
that time to kill in that game which is
like even longer than this at least I'm
not forgetting would be alive yeah oh
it's hide in the sewer here Shangaan
play your own ring around the Rosie was
the same guy almost got to get spawn
kills on him the classic or I can be in
their spawn exactly
hello game we got some smoke I wonder if
like this is not a good map perspective
I guess you could go through these like
little areas
like worry about thank you I just want
to heal it's not good positioning it's
all coming back to me chat sort of like
riding a bike I really now I'm gonna die
like three times I said all that kind of
big yeah it's very it's very big life
all right so they could go from there
oh yeah he's like so right here right
here right yeah it's okay let's see how
bad it is okay point eight three it's
fixable it's fixable we've got plenty of
diamond
I hope though it's only thirty two
seventeen wedding by the way so my
teammates are putting that putting me in
their backpack moral support oh okay
are you guys gonna die to them all right
so we've seen WMV this is artifact the
other format buried and Hacienda
Twilight all right it's okay I get to
use this all those points okay it's
hoping to get a double didn't even get a
double almost there
that second guy was pretty weak it's
hard though to get double kills and
stuff like like you can use silencers
right so you can see from the map
but it nurse the damage so it makes it
even more difficult I feel like being
exposed on the map on top with like I
want to run faster to my left
it's come back even the game knows yeah
that was for range actually I know I
just did the role I'll say your oh crap
really I am a late and you just got
there so I thought I rolled because I
remember your button
I saw the where are they I know I ran a
circle oh my goodness always yeah see
this does seem like good area come on
let's cut the grass yeah I gave up at
that point leaf there was that k-6 might
kill oh really
our team is dominating them that bad or
you get you a BSS
[Music]
wow that hit by your accuracy
I know right and that three level three
sensitivity yeah got mad packs can we
not go up there we go
no you won't let me clamber okay I can
and I just don't know how does it sweet
good I'm so used to going to 75 there
was totally so he's not flame thrower
amazing oh he died though mandis these
guys are killing him so fast that
there's nothing to do you're just
getting your cardio I yeah I'm like
running laps your Specter is gonna have
the glutes of a god
yeah like seriously like we have not
done anything in a long time oh there we
go
the final kill
what a waste of and all this is not a
good memory unless you get to their
spawning they're just yeah this is what
happens if you play with a bunch of good
friends and you're just like oh they're
killing everyone great can't even shoot
at anyone
alright let's try the blackout oh you
want to see if there's another okay
that's Paris Paris if not yeah I like
that that's good keep me from spamming
back right away
all right let's I'm pretty sure I got to
one Katie but you never know I could it
was dicey it was dicey alright we
survived we survived all right let's see
you wanted alright so check out blackout
alright let's see how this goes right to
get all the maps you guys I gotta go
it's not it's not a multiplayer right
yeah so I actually have not tried this
mode oh no that makes it different it's
so instead of like traditional like wait
wait oh sorry
instead of like traditional Call of Duty
what you would imagine it to be its
battle royale crime says blackout says
launch week so this might not be
equipped with no way there's no way I
don't believe that
oh there's bounty hunter quads though
this is probably really fun alright so
we can do that it's probably extremely
thick Specter oops I think I mean like
just like visually yeah probably because
in this mode everyone can become Specter
that's fair that's fair
I don't even know why let's just go
let's just do this you must find the
shadow blade to play it ok so you have
to find the weapon first and then yeah
the Romanovs confusing because then some
of this stuff it was like yeah it's in
it and I'm like cool and then some of
its like not like prop it says prop ones
in like a launch week but I guess it is
launch week because Friday is still in
the week but I wish it was alright toast
on fire maybe we'll run into you oh you
want to get cut up
alright so find the blade become Specter
and assassinate your way to the top so
we got to find oh no it happens
although the flooding and stuff happened
so that's what happened the dam broke if
you didn't know and so now it's like
kind of like put water across the map in
certain areas and so you can't like
there's more like you want to use the
boats and stuff more because that's the
thing in the in this mode is like
there's vehicles you can use vehicles to
like get to the circles and things like
that we'll see how long I live though
cuz as it is about array all Lots might
be here a couple times
oh wait yeah a squad so we got to try to
find the sword
I guess so in this game to this game
type mode I mean I'm sure you're
familiar with battle Royales but you
pick up all your stuff I think their
inventory system is not great so that'll
be fun okay there's just people with
regular clothes I'm civilians
I always like the shotgun we'll take a
silencer it's like you're just sneezing
on them all right so in seven seconds I
wonder how scary the person with the
sword is to it depends right like do
they get unlimited smoke grenades that
would be kind of scary
I see where they want to drop to oh are
those all sorts where are we going oh
you my team my team kind of drops only
half your team drop I want to go to one
I don't know what the purple things are
I'm assuming that the store might be the
sword so you ever the first one to know
what there's people going there okay no
everything's bad everything's bad y'all
mistakes were made
okay this is the first time not even
with my team i or drop here and hope
that we get a gun we should oh they mark
it - I'm so sorry I'm a bad teammate I
saw I saw shinies and I was like I'm
gonna go to it just my footsteps
what's up to key grain yes my name is
Persia Oh someone's through a smoke
already I want to be the inspector this
bridge I can only imagine somebody yeah
I shouldn't went in the water
no the light's gone that means oh oh
the swords back oh no some guy just ran
you guys on the other strand can't be
sneaky what if this light means
absolutely no no no there's too many
lights - oh no oh - he went up there oh
come back here shoot some bullets till I
get him to come over
maybe Batum dude this is gonna we're
gonna be trucking he's so fast
we're marathon and oh he's going to the
asylum I think clean up some folks we've
lost vision I know can't lose vision of
the assassin Oh as a party party in the
asylum it's so edgy supply drop in chops
like looting
it's like more nerve-wracking now that
we have no idea where you went so scary
I just want armor oh there you go yeah
level one now it's fine it's better than
nothing
[Music]
asylum is jammin I guess so nowhere that
Specter was right now I wonder how much
damage the armor - that would be crazy
feel like you jayhawk though he got a
spectacle I saw it in the deed I was
like 13
oh very bad these footsteps are so loud
it's freaking me out
like is that just me or someone rolling
up it's because I had dead silence on
all my classes we were using so now this
puts up super loud okay that makes sense
it was it was really freaking me out
I was like man is the spectre behind me
because he's about the chop shop means
can you pick up perks yeah so he's this
you can get which we call it that
silence steps
welcome to be our folks I know right or
you just watch someone weed for me time
I sleep for tonight or apex it's like me
looting for the entire game and then I
finally get to one battle and I know and
I'm like no I felt so equipped that game
but apparently not I was so sure we
could catch up to the spectre because I
thought you know now we're in this corn
maze I came we're in the circle though
yeah well I think they're really far
though which is good oh there's purple
there's so far though I think Oh all the
purple lights near you banished oh oh
there's a person you just ran into you
think so you don't think he went in
Duluth oh wait
all right well I'll take your word for
I'm going for the purple light I'm
hoping he saw the same thing I did
I've never shot this gun before they
grabbed but we'll see if that's the next
class five bullets so I'm gonna go with
hopefully automatic here we'll go
rampart we knew our APR is a pulse or
like a battle rifle BR oh nice three
bears I'm scared though I'd rather have
a yeah give me much Oh No
gunfire it's bait
because the other thing about this which
actually makes sense why there might be
a lot of them older over there hippie
boy a far away's people with camping and
range just go from sort
oh there's another oh oh my god oh my
god you've got a lot of armor right if
the graph is a fully auto alright we're
gonna get to it we're gonna get to a
sword
holy smokes he's got armor three armor
hey no like that's not an assassin okay
alright we try again now we know now we
know it was definitely abating that I
was like there so yeah I think you're
right there's something we did smoke do
you see a stupid cuz at first I thought
there was just like three spectres
around you but I don't think no this is
the same guy unlimited smoke
I don't know we'll see we have to get
the sword to find out it's possible it
wasn't exactly one hit no look like one
hit I don't know it looked like one here
I level - armor - I don't maybe armor
doesn't matter though katana pretty much
he's fast too scary yeah that was
terrifying
seeing a juggernut shaped guy with that
speed or a katana this time I will try
to drop with my team well no one marked
it at first and then I was like all
right Chinese I'm gonna go to the
Chinese also I'm a because I play apex
mainly as a br I'm so used to it has um
the flight master so one person usually
controls where you go but in this you
can kind of just like do whatever you
want
I surprised they don't have the thing in
here free to mess around with whatever
man I can only imagine this is what I
needed on it the spectre inspector
battle I still wouldn't have died
oh yeah like us like a sword fight yeah
it'll be like samurai shodown that looks
good actually
I'm curious they did come by and we did
I didn't get to play it but I heard
there's like some that is it s f4 s f5
guys working on it
do you know much about the new center
not too much but I watch some gameplay
it does look pretty fun yeah did you
play like yeah used to go to the arcade
to play that when I was a kid go to like
Pizza Hut you go wait for the pizza that
come out like grandma in quarter I
always play like The Simpsons
that's a quarter that's a quarter eater
yeah marge is cheap yeah
she's got the spinny vacuum move 360
hitboxes those masks
that's can't sell that sure
and she's got like a diet kick are we
going one guy dropped ready all right
we're going man where's where are they
not going that's what I let's hope that
no one's going to that yeah you're like
right on top oh man that guy's going in
hot
I know are you going for that far away
yeah where's my team come to me oh wait
my team know very close to be using the
last team left yeah I think you can make
your way back man wet socks my most
hated actually one of my top five I need
actually armor why not save me from the
oh I should be melee for whatever reason
low on a downed person is I insta kill
at least it wasn't that alcatraz mode
you gotta like it up close that look
like a specter it didn't he look like
he's moving pretty slow originally
no Armour hello Norman welcome to the
stream thanks for tuning in we're just
kind of playing some of the new black
ops 4 modes this week is action-packed
and fully loaded with new updates and
whatnot we got to check out a couple of
the new new masks while WMD is like a
new old map and then we also play those
artifacts yeah I was not used to that
one that map looks like it would be
awesome if you had like a sniper's nest
or a chopper of some sort my whole team
did oh you're the last one you know I
didn't get the sword we're leaving get
all the kids on it alright there's a
purple over there there's a purple beam
of light you have one minute circle
close circle begins and I don't care I
want the sword this is the perfect time
actually to go through this aw really
yes oh I for it oh alright it's okay
we're gonna fight it yeah focus focus
we're gonna find out hopefully they come
this way they'd be probably running the
same direction hi bee bee hives
if that's how you pronounce you sounds
like yeah this is quads imagine all for
your teammates have you all having it
that would be nice
we're healthy now no no use that now I'm
more aware all right do we go back for
that one any vehicle mm-hmm oh you're
going for that one I bet that guy's
going for it definitely going for it
he's got his eye on the fryer yeah I
don't have a vehicle to get there though
take the chain take the train yeah hi
what is uh what is the next train right
into the specter the the shadow blade
yes please where is it it's that purple
beam of light well my guess is like that
buggy that just went over this hill went
for it yeah fight him for it oh it's
gone he made it
nope it's still there oh there it is I
was just hiding more fighting though
okay oh it's gone well it's alright it's
our time to die oh wait the circle is
coming in no huh I'm doing this is not
good we're just Yolo right now oh yeah
okay I guess I have an advantage is to
like oh there's two it's a sword fight
going on over there
will we make it in time we're just gonna
die silly Jack oh oh man oh the storms
are closing in who cares you said Yolo
right yes we got this if you just grab
it and run you should be good let him go
let him go let him go let him go wasting
valuable time
oh it's upstairs it's okay did we did we
get guy is that not no I got it okay Oh
time to go you're fast not to say it
would be able to keep up in the storm I
got a heal at some point can I take the
buggy yeah get me out of here see if
it's worth it kind of let me pick it
will be fine
wait look here right real quick look how
many lights are over there yeah the
force bar is there just one spectra
camping the packets of shadow boyega
slice and everyone
at 37
okay so armor is still tied to what you
pick up even if you are
even it was we're gonna make it okay
that was a jump are we good
oh let me out boy exit open I'm right
see it was worth it
dare you just mainly I was spamming it
seven help dang it I only try one more
time
yes that's so sad so sad right now that
guy's life flashed before his eyes so
had you gotten one swing into the stream
I wouldn't have mattered at that point
like and that is I get a spectre girl in
black out you guys good night so sad
right now feels bad man
you're so bad you went into the danger
zone to to get that thing it was fine
you you've made the right call Yolo who
cares just get the sword Danny and there
was a nice little vehicle it's fine it's
fine
profound sadness
[Music]
cute oh wait that was a fun game it
wasn't fun I should have killed that guy
I mean you were the only one on your
team over a hot minute that's true
that's true that's all got sliced oh
yeah
I'll try but like somebody has to
actually like pinpoint a spot in the map
so we'll see you maybe I think yeah as I
take some initiative this is indeed
black ops for we're checking out some of
the new updates and DLCs we got to check
out some of the new map additions
we've been playing Specter all day it's
been really fun slicing and dicing some
folks hello death scythe who we are
chillin thanks for joining us I guess
they weren't ready for you all right day
one yeah so fun fact not that well it is
matrix related but in like one of the
John the latest John wick trailers you
know when he he goes in he says like
what do you need like guns lots of them
is the same line from the matrix alright
I guess I guess I'm like no copyright
maybe that's just not a line that
matters but yeah it's just can I get to
do it everyone sounds true
who wouldn't you uh like a long time ago
I heard that Will Smith they want to
will submit to play neo and then he
turned it down
that's how Keanu got it that role Wow
and now you'll he'll be forever
remembered as neo and what is going on
neo and John wick and then whoever he
was an appointment was a Point Break
have you not seen the replaceable
oh yes that's fine I guess the
quarterback I forgot his name ready I
know I don't always think about that
movie that's fair I heard people didn't
like raking with him because he smelled
that really but I was like I'd work with
them have you smelled bad anyways no you
don't know that is this not working I
know did we get kicked out or the top
tier Specter please yes exactly
or the lack thereof they're like you're
not worthy of holding this blade
I'll give it a couple more tries if it
doesn't work I know we can either play
okay there you go hopefully there we go
alright it's your last chance last
chance I know I thought we were gonna
get it there I was like oh he's in range
no he actually used to sniper to to kill
me which is actually pretty impressive
but he needed all that damage and
precision just in oh yeah cuz you didn't
have the armor yet Oh cuz I had I only
had seven life from because he grenaded
me I'm like oh no he knows what to do if
almost like he didn't even see you
though and he rolled out of the oh yeah
I know right
he's like oh he's so dead it's like oh
wait why are you coming out
yeah so I think I saw hydro damage
caused a huge kind of flood so there's a
bunch of watery areas now on the map so
that's how they changed their their map
to kind of spice it up or black out I'm
kind of curious like I want to know like
raw data like if there's more majority
people playing blackout or if they're
just playing like the more traditional
OTE kind of modes right I kind of feel
like at this point for most of us
they're like well we have to have some
sort of battle royale boom now dad was
like alright let's throw in blackout
we'll still have our regular multiplayer
cover all eight pieces and they got
zombies and zombies aren't black I think
all right all right we'll try to pick a
spot and hope that the homies come after
if they don't then what can I do
all right let's see if we can land with
D all right let's see where do we want
to go why are you guys all late they see
the purple Chinese - oh is it we're
trying to go far and hope that I just
realized that this map was all of the
regular maps put into one so that's
pretty cool wow man everyone are screwed
we're not getting that one all right
change of plans we're gonna go grab
stuff from the train station and hope
that we can kill the guy that has the
blade Oh cuz someone just picked it up
100%
Bob Jim says you didn't like battery
also not all SES games need it I agree I
think all FPS games they don't need it
sometimes originality is cute yeah
chasing the trends Oh wasn't someone
trying to like sue over the I guess the
idea of a battle royale oh really
they were like bizarre concept and I was
like I don't yeah all right so someone
killed him for the sword we're gonna try
to clean it up yeah oh my whole team is
dead sick okay Oh sword is gone alright
you gotta want to come to train station
right because you're like I need armor
I was only shooting him from far away
where he's gonna run up and cut me in
one
here it the math all always in there
he's in there he's in there go pick up
the sword dude I don't think he sees you
yet you're just bait that's like his
homie out there there's too much going
on
did he take it out I don't think he did
he was away Brea I wouldn't do one more
because I have control of that I'm
pretty sure the outcomes the same I
should have just shot him
really yeah but I saw the armor and I
was like I don't know if I can kill him
and that was poor judgment because you
would have shot at him at least nerf
some of that arm right so that when you
got closer but I mean once the sniper
shot came out of left field I'm so
screwed yeah we needed to rethink that
game plan real quick save me
hey I already took my lumps in know you
I would say you did better than like the
majority if a big sample size right like
every or four or five games I would say
four out of five we're good oh my game
so far black out specifically I've had
one mediocre game where I was like I
killed someone that didn't have a gun
and then I got the sword and then I died
and then in these other two examples we
didn't even come close so it's going
it's going importantly it was within I
just wanted to kill him get a kill and
then we'd be fine it didn't matter if we
didn't but then battle royale happened
so that's not entirely your fault either
I was right on the cusp of slashing that
guy's toes and then he I feel it this
round though all right I hope that your
optimism
is correct and not in this place you
know what is it fifth time's a charm
right exactly if we don't get here it
makes you feel alive alright maybe maybe
my teammates will drop in the same spot
but I kind of doubt that
I think everyone just see the the shiny
and is just chasing the one that's
closest to the fire I would what's that
that looks so pretty dead slightly
scared wow the anticipation I know I
almost rather just play the TD
everything Hey
all right let me see oh no I don't want
that I don't definitely know what that
hot so laggy I just let me play Specter
right we just want to slice and dice you
know I just want to be a fake Genji
hello chalky I says what's in this
update so we just tried out some
blackout in which they have this bounty
hunter mode so you saw there's like
Spectre the shadow blade was everywhere
you got to pick it up all that jazz but
then in the multiplayer mode they have
some new maps some new old maps to you
WMD artifact masquerade Hacienda
Twilight is a new alternative Mass and
then the spectre class that's new to the
update also later this week we're gonna
get prop hunch which I'm excited about
it's actually really fun and hilarious
game time and then capture the flag good
old CTF when I'm talking about crap do
we get any no it's like do we get a new
map we did not whatever would we try to
at least kills don't want the sword and
then it doesn't even matter at that
just like yep we got some sword or Eric
killed someone yeah sorry is pretty fun
it's actually pretty busted in this
multiplayer mode it's like one slice the
lunge range is pretty good no back out
just back out we're snow researching we
are playing some specters only for the
show we're trying to provide some
quality content for you guys too slow
for one this is the first time we got
blocked out of yeah prop hunt that's
okay we wanted a new map anyways yeah we
want to try to show up one of the newer
maps I still want to see masquerade
because it sounds like it's really fun
is it I would assume like it's not one
of those that they're holding I would
hope that they're not holding it back
don't put me in the same game oh so
Bowman if you bought the pack and you
need to download it we actually went to
the section here in multiplayer or not
earlier but the menu before black market
and then we got it from here yeah we got
Specter from there and there's the shop
in the main menu had the other maps that
we had to actually manually download so
yeah if you don't have it take a look
around to your black market into the
store that's in the main menu cuz we
struggle with that too that's the only
one
yeah I get greedy to like have less
points for white and hopefully we can
get Specter and call it a day
hello to you - Benjamin welcome to the
stream he said what have I missed
oh boy we've just been slicing and
dicing you were slicing and dicing we've
also been getting sliced in taste
I did a roll and then nothing happened
that's what happened for me and I ran
this whole map just now and killed one
person with my sword and that's it right
we got that quality cardio yeah don't
skip leg day or a cardio day I guess
cardio baby okay I got to be fast got it
I guess we should use your ramparts
because we need a little bit of range
it's Maps a little bit bigger alright
let's just hope for quality slights
hacking slashing hey Bowman if you're
missing your DLC you should try to
download it physically from the store in
the game and the black market because
that's where we found our content when
it says ours was missing kid unless you
want to play for some reason after it's
okay although it was fun Spectre is
definitely a really fun class like if I
play again this week I'm definitely
going to want it to hell you saw the
other guy like sometimes it's better
just follow that let them trickle out
he was waiting for me he was trying to
camp it in the canyons both my dad I can
give this guy double kill we got our
smoke grenade - yeah I just don't know
where to use it on this map cuz it's so
open
yeah I probably go away like I liked all
the maps you have cool yeah
dang he was hungry for it yes he's
bloodthirsty and he had the silencer so
I had no idea where he was is this gonna
be like the opposite of that one time we
head shots this is this map is called
artifact this is one of the new
additions with this patch we were
desperately trying to get masquerade but
we didn't even see it in the vote why
did I shot the other guy
and looking gee life has its pros and
cons like up close
Cindy good but my aim at a distance so
bad I take their guns quickscope we're
gonna sit here and hope that he spawns
again at the moment at least they won't
be the best area in here to camp yeah we
know silence oh geez everyone knows it's
got to keep on moving I mean in theory
this is a good sniper matter
that's Gators last map I mean top tier
plays here oh yeah where we're setting
that up for later get you I have one cue
in a second oh yeah we got it yeah I
think martinis are pushing your sponsee
yeah definitely run around those canyons
and work all day all day all day these
little canyons
we're not terrible we're not great
really down by six
Wow there's only three behind me that's
no problem to stay in all these little
crevices watch you're right that was
scary
don't get some feels real quick yeah I
would just stay in this pet running
circles gotta stay in that kit I should
have that suppose for some reason your
team just staying in it love that
outside their never ending another side
of the map
hot maybe if we get sword gotta like
those clothes he had the jump on YouTube
let's just say you got a sleigh out
exterminators what oh I was gonna dance
you can die on one of those see your gun
you have a better gun
I could tell you've been killing me with
it
we're only halfway to a sword yeah let's
go take another back your honor feels
good oh my legs that's good don't need
those look at that it's super shiny
diamond D you know I remember when I
first I thought it was like the whole
gun was like a giant diamond oh I was
like oh there's diamonds on this smoke
again the movement was too good Oh
Godzilla just chopping people up got
triple are you trying to get kills right
now because we're about to lose and I'm
so close to the sword but I don't think
we're gonna get there
comeback time guess save the team I'm
hot Rangers you got this literally the
hot spot with the geyser
yeah it's okay they won't tell they
won't show it they won't know only only
stream knows only stream knows how did
the guy that got three sword kills not
get it and he called in his like where's
the fourth all right wasn't never saw us
on this kill came here we played some
flops today you guys we we shot up some
Fulk we sliced up some Bullock we got to
see two of the new maps new editions yep
yep
so yeah thanks for joining us we had fun
really loud sorry we won something
yeah that song with us winning yeah yeah
21 and 18 by the way I just like to work
out it wasn't it wasn't some proof it's
okay it wasn't great it wasn't terrible
we're right in the average is how so
thank you guys so much for tuning in
yeah make sure you come back Monday
through Friday 11:00 a.m. I'm also gonna
throw a shout-out to Thursday's show
because we're gonna have clockwork in
the house the legendary clockwork and
he's gonna be playing and showing off
some of the new patch for battle for the
grid the Power Rangers fighting game
which is definitely gonna shake things
up we got some new characters some major
changes to gameplay and an all-around
good time so make sure you guys tune in
for that and yeah just have an awesome
day and we'll see you guys next time bye
you